Speaker 1: major breaking news. This this
is this is absolutely huge. The prosecutor,
who resigned recently from the Trump criminal
probe now says that Trump is guilty of numerous
felonies beyond a reasonable doubt. This is not
a I'm going to pat myself on the back story,
but it sort of is in the sense that when we
learned that these prosecutors resigned from
the Trump probe, right wingers everywhere were
saying they resigned because they realized it
was a witch hunt. And at the time, I said, there's
no evidence of that. And if we want to speculate,
it seems more plausible to me that the prosecutors
investigating Trump resigned because they realized
there's not actually any willingness to charge the
guy. And they found wrongdoing. That is exactly
what one of the prosecutors now says. This story
cannot be cannot be understated in its importance.
Former Manhattan prosecutor believed
Trump was guilty of numerous felonies.
One of the prosecutors, who had been leading
the Manhattan District Attorney's investigation
into former President Trump and the Trump
Organization, said in his resignation letter that
he believed Trump was quote guilty of numerous
felony violations, per the New York Times.
His financial statements were false, and he
has a long history of fabricating information
relating to his personal finances, lying
about his assets to banks, the national media,
counterparties and many others, including the
American people. This is Mark Pomerantz who wrote
this in his resignation letter. The team that has
been investigating Trump harbors no doubt about
whether he committed crimes. He did. I and others
have advised you that we have evidence sufficient
to establish Trump's guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt. And we believe that the prosecution
would prevail if charges were brought. And the
matter were tried to an impartial jury. No case is
perfect. Whatever the risks of bringing the case
may be, I am convinced that a failure to prosecute
will pose much greater risks in terms of public
confidence in the Fair Administration of Justice.
This is one of the biggest stories around
presidential wrongdoing and criminality in
decades in decades, and the right is ignoring
it. Pomerantz also expressed his concerns that
not proceeding would doom future efforts at
prosecuting Trump in related cases. Guys,
I hate to be, I know it sounds like I'm patting
myself on the back, but. They were just so wrong.
And my speculation turned out to be not just
pointing in the right direction. It is exactly
what Pomeranz is saying took place. This is
exactly what he says is going on. We suspected
there is serious hesitation from days to be
the first to prosecute a former president.
My prediction was if one prosecution went
forward, then a whole bunch of others would. But
who wants to be the first because admittedly
this is politically unstable ground?
And it is historically unstable ground, and it's a
big deal to charge a former president, I get that.
But my sense was that these investigators were
resigning, not because there was no evidence
and they were being forced to put together a
case against Trump. But my instinct was they're
resigning because they're they're realizing
their work is going to be put in the toilet
and flushed 10 to 15 times, as Donald Trump
likes to say. They were finding wrongdoing.
And these are extraordinarily strong words
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt that we
would be able to clearly establish in front of
a jury of the commission of multiple felonies.
When did we last hear prosecutor speak that
way about the actions of a sitting or former
sitting president? It is arguably unprecedented,
and they realize my boss isn't going to charge
Trump. He's not going to do it. So what
the hell am I doing here doing this work?
What we do know is they are hesitant about
charging Trump and that I understand that,
but we now know the real reason why
they resigned. And it is exactly exactly
what I suspected was going on. If there is a
miscarriage of justice here. It's that Trump
has not been charged. I want to hear from you.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman. Let me know
your thoughts. The David Pakman Show is not only
buoyed by, but depends on the support of our
viewers and our listeners. You can sign up for
a David Pakman Show membership at join Packman
dot com and you can use the coupon code wwr 22 to
get a discount. If you so please, we actually do
an extra show every day for our members, and
I would love to see you in membership ranks.